this morning an alert from the Food and
Drug Administration about a popular
heartburn medication small amounts of a
cancer-causing chemical have been found
in zantac as well as in generic forms of
the drug known as ranitidine the FDA is
not issuing a recall and says patients
can continue taking that medication zan
tax maker Sanofi says it takes patient
safety seriously and is committed to
working with the FDA CBS News medical
contributor dr. David agus has more on
all of this doctor good morning Marni
Jeff so last year the same chemical was
linked to dozens of recalls in blood
pressure drugs why why not now this is a
chemical that's involved in the that
when you make ranitidine or zantac and
it was found in quantities they haven't
said how much my gut is you know they
don't know all of the details yet they
found it originally in June they're
telling us now there are alternative
medicines on the market that do the same
thing if it were me and I were taking
zantac I would probably switch to
another drug for also why yeah why not
err on the side of caution here at this
point I don't know why the FDA didn't
air but I certainly would and I advise
our viewers to probably get a different
medicine this is a compound that's
present in food we know the
concentrations they found in zantac were
higher than that seen in food but in the
statement they weren't high enough to
cause a recall that being said I would
probably just switch medicines now
things that don't have NDMA to our
knowledge there are different zan tax
there's prescription and there's also
over-the-counter so if you have a
prescription or over-the-counter what
are you looking at they're both
different strength
okay so over-the-counter is just the
lower strength one talk to your doctor
and say what's on an alternative that I
can do whether prescription or not to
help your stomach know all right dr.
David agus thanks for all that good
information we'll see you a bit later in
morning rounds I'd be here all right
they're working you hearts it all right